how are you thank you for doing that
yeah absolutely
nice to have you here congratulations on
everything thank you thank you yeah you
know it's it's it's funny you're someone
I've actually wanted to talk to you for
a while because we have some stuff in
common which is we're both Bostonians oh
yeah we're from the great city of Boston
and I'm curious about something cuz when
I saw you in Good Will Hunting you had a
Boston accent you had the sort of the
Massachusetts accent you don't have it
in real life though right well and I get
asked a lot and how did you lose the
Boston accent well I I always think that
I lost it or I guess I never really had
it but apparently when I start talking
really fast it comes out I'm told that
it comes out like right I just get you
know carried away and I start talking
like this and I you know there's
something a Bruins jersey sprouts on
yeah and it's like come on be Brooklyn
I am from Brooklyn outside Boston and
what happened with us is we don't I
don't think any of us really have Boston
accents but sometimes we looked at films
of us our dad took films of us when we
were kids and for some reason all of us
when I'm like eight years old we're
talking about kya Stransky we have
really thick ones we look like these
little thugs and then I guess it goes
away at some point yeah I guess so I
guess so that's funny though to think of
you at anything Conan come up the house
get your car you stravsky Jersey Rock a
marijuana busy eating beans are you we
should talk about the Red Sox a little
bit because last year everyone last
season everyone said diehard Boston fans
said this is the year they're gonna
everyone thought it was gonna be this
sort of millennial gift that they're
gonna beat the Yankees are gonna beat
the Mets
well that why because they were gonna
meet the Yankees in the playoffs and
that would have been the first time
because of the wild-card and it was just
all it was all slotted to happen last
year and yeah that was that was a that
was a tough one for all of us I actually
was doing a movie in in Georgia that
Robert Redford was directing and he's a
huge Red Sox fan actually oh really
a huge Ted Williams fan he and he told
me that if they made it to Game seven in
Yankee Stadium that we could take the
day off and go up to the game he just
said we you know we can
forget about this whole movie and just
just get on a plane and shut down a
movie
he was literally willing to shut down
the movie because he realized the
significance of the game you know do you
believe in the curse do you think
there's a curse yeah absolutely I do too
anybody from Boston I think thinks
there's a curse on me I think the only
cure for the curse she's so happy to see
you she'll cheer anything you say I hear
lavas pouring down in the city did it's
funny though I mean I actually I was
thinking about it today I was thinking
what would end the curse and I think
it's a human sacrifice yeah I think of a
famous Boston celebrity were sacrificed
the curse would be over so you see
there's a reason for my coming on the
show grab Amanda yeah no we'll get
someone else we're gonna die now or
something will trick him into it not you
now you know what's amazing is you win
the Oscar for your screenplay so how old
were you when that have you very wins
them 27 you get an Oscar for your
screenplay you and Ben Affleck that's
got to be surreal itself I mean when you
were 26 your career wasn't off the
ground then you're 27 right yeah when I
was 26
really nothing was happening at all I
mean career not off the ground is
putting it pretty mildly and I
appreciate that but are you living in
the street the studio like Conan stop
picture please all right and I shoved
you into trash cans and said that kid
will never make it exactly he's sorry
about that no no that was a whole
surreal thing in at the at the at the
risk of ending up on Real Audio with
Robert Smigel I actually something
happened to me that night where I went
into the bathroom at the Governor's Ball
and Charlton Heston was was I was going
to the bathroom you know at the bank of
urinals and I and I looked up and I saw
Moses standing next to that that was
kind of the capper for the you know I
have the Oscar on top of the urinal and
Moses next to me you know
did he part the water in there though
sacrilegious he'll get letters now you
know let's talk let's not the current
movie talented mr. Ripley reading a
quote from Gwyneth Paltrow about your
performance and she has a quote she
calls you a real brave son of a [ __ ]
for doing something in the movie what
was she talking about she was talking
about the the bathing suit that I wore
what was brave about this bathing suit
well they painted my body just sheet
white and and just basically slabbed on
this alabaster paint and and sent me out
in this lime-green speedo and the whole
point was that I had just kind of
arrived in Italy and everybody else was
really tan and combat bullying right and
my worst nightmare would be taking off
my clothes and putting on this
lime-green speedo that's most men's
worst nightmare let's I think we have
the photo here let's take a look at that
yeah there I just thought we'd show that
are you wearing looks like a diaper
actual paper
they're kind of that style doesn't come
in to favor some junior depends you know
actually I thought you might do that so
I did a little research before I came
and and I think I have a picture of you
yeah and it's some nice attire do we do
we have that that's actually better than
I look on the beach that's some
photographer did some photographer
talking to me it'll be great just trust
me just trust white and it's dress is
gonna be good for you older cover of GQ
didn't make the cover did in in we have
a clip here from the movie and I'm
curious do we need to know it's it's
catch a complicated film yeah people
love this film by the way but it's it's
a complicated idea yeah yeah yeah this
is actually I get sent to Italy to bring
back this rich kid who's over there
blowing through his trust fund and I'm a
poor kid and very much an outsider who
wants this this dolce vita that all
these people are living and and so in
this scene I go over and I actually do
an impression of his father for him and
and in this little clip I think he's he
grabs me because his girlfriend who's
Gweneth and Jude Law is this the guy
that I'm over there to get Jude grabs me
and to show his girlfriend the way I'm
imitating his father and saying meet my
father meet my father
cool let's take a look at this clip from
the talented mr. Ripley Mars this is
scary
you've gotta hear this leap my father
Herbert which is really the first
pleasure to meet you
Dicky's made a fine catch I'm Teddy I
know Emily things so uncanny could you
ever conceive of going to Italy tongue
and bringing him back what I pay you if
you would go to Italy persuade my son to
come home I pay you a thousand dollars
I'm feeling great you you had to learn
you had to learn in classical piano for
this role is that right yeah yeah I did
it actually got cut out the songs I
learned they made you learn classical
piano and then they cut it they cut it
out yeah but uh but yeah it was yeah I
was sorry to see it go and they they cut
out the scene where you're set on fire
and I had to learn that one too and then
a thousand eggs all right we're cutting
that yeah
nice people well the talented mr. Ripley
is in theaters now and it's doing great
and Matt great to have you on the show
yeah graduations on every day
[Applause]